This is Jocko podcast number five with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo,
Gerald [inaudible] evening.
Welcome to podcast number five.
Here we are.
Here we are number five.
Thank you everyone for joining us.
So tonight
I got asked on Twitter
a,
could you talk about coaching some people and that kind of prompted me to think
about something that I have pulled out in the past when I'm teaching some
leadership classes.
And what this is is to counseling notes that I wrote for sessions when I was
trying to help a couple of seal leaders improve themselves and get better.
And the first one was for a seal that was a buddy of mine and who was a little
bit junior to me,
just a little bit junior and me in rank.
But you know,
because I was a prior enlisted seal,
I had actually been in the seal teams for a much longer time and this guy was a
real great,
great leader,
great guy,
and very passionate about Duna a solid job and very passionate about the seal
teams,
which is an awesome thing to see.
And with that passion,
and I've said this before,
sometimes your strength can be your weakness and sometimes he would get a little
bit too passionate about stuff and a little bit emotional and B be a little bit
easy to read.
And
so I was in a meeting with him and I kind of saw how he was acting and I saw how
other people were reacting to him.
And so when I saw that I kind of sat down and just put some words on paper to
let him know that he had a little area of improvement.
And what's good about this is,
you know,
I was the detached person,
so I was able to sit outside the situation.
It just watch and see,
oh that's that.
He's not coming across the way he thinks he's coming across.
And so I'm gonna start off with that one is pretty positive echo when you,
when you say put words on paper,
is that like an official thing?
You know,
like when you get written up at work or something,
it's like,
here's your official warning,
right?
This one was not,
this was just a bro.
Say Amen.
Here's some,
here's some tips.
Almost like a deal note almost.
Yeah.
Note.
Yep.
Yeah,
this is a DL note.
So what's interesting is there's,
there's,
in the seal teams,
there's not a lot of writing up all in this,
in this capacity.
So if somebody has a safety violation where they do something unsafe,
that gets written up immediately.
But this type of thing is a little bit,
you know,
because normally you're just trying to bring someone along and help them out and
improve their leadership.
You know,
it's just mentoring.
So a lot of times that you don't need a document when you're trying to help out
your buddies.
The reason,
that's why I'm kind of lucky here,
I forget what it was,
but I,
you know,
I went to a meeting,
he was in it and I kind of forget the situation,
but for whatever reason I wrote this down and I think I sent it to him and said,
hey,
let's talk about this later.
But just,
just wanting to give you this stuff,
you know,
now.
And so I'm kind of lucky that I wrote it down is kind of like in the spirit of
organization.
Yeah.
And just,
I think it was more of just,
I couldn't talk to him immediately for whatever reason.
And so I just sent him an email and said,
hey bro,
where I like left it on his desk,
I forget if it was digital is probably email.
But so
here we go
and there's,
there's some interesting comments in here and that's why I think I saved it.
And that's why I think it's,
it's good conversation.
So here we go.
Here's my note to a seal leader.
That
is it,
buddy.
Tried to try to move along is leadership paradigm.
And here we go.
One leadership is getting people to do things.
This is a form of manipulation.
So right there,
I use this word that everybody hates manipulation.
And people often replace that word with influence.
And I do it too.
You know what saying,
Oh,
you want to use your influence.
But what you're really saying is you want to manipulate people,
but it's very negative.
And the way I break that down,
the way I separate that from something negative and something positive,
as if I'm trying to manipulate you in a negative way,
that means I want you to do something that's going to benefit me and it's gonna
hurt you.
To me,
that's manipulation of that's negative.
But if you're trying to influence someone,
you're trying to lead them,
you're still manipulating them,
but you're trying to get something that's going to be positive for them and
positive for the team.
So as far as I'm concerned,
when you're influencing someone,
you're really manipulating them for a positive outcome.
So,
but that being said,
I think people need to recognize that.
And that's why I use that word because everyone knows what manipulation as
you're trying to get someone to do something right.
And that's what leadership is.
If you think about it,
you're trying to get someone to do something,
but I use that word.
So it's very clear what you're trying to do.
Leadership is nothing more than getting people to do what you want,
both up and down the chain of command.
So not just the people below.
You want the people above you to do what you want them to do.
More importantly,
getting them to,
to want to do what you want them to do is the best form of leadership and the
highest form of manipulation.
So this is a situation where you don't even want you,
you want the person just to want to do what you're getting them to do,
right?
So now I go on.
Every time we open our mouths to speak to another person,
our goal is to get them to do what we want them to do.
Otherwise,
why the hell are we talking?
So everything you say,
the tone of your voice,
that the words you choose,
the inflection on those words and body language and facial expression are all
tools to be used to make progress in getting your way or tools that you Ms.
Hughes and isolate yourself and move away from your goals.
So again,
I wanted to make sure that this guy knew that every little facial expression,
everything that he said and how he said it,
all those things have an impact because people forget that you'll realize how
important your words are and how important your facial expressions are and how
important your tone is and how that impacts people.
Okay?
You are always in negotiation.
Everything you say and do and the manner in which you say and do it has an
impact on future outcomes.
Pretty simple.
Now,
this is
when I say this to people,
they go,
oh,
so here it is.
The best way to win is when the other person doesn't know you won.
And if possible,
might not even know there was a fight.
If your ego requires the constant food,
a victory,
you can never win in this manner.
So just to restate that,
the best way to win in a,
in a competition of getting something,
getting something to happen,
or getting some,
someone do something.
The best way to win is when they don't even know that you won.
And even better than that is that they don't even know that there was a game.
They don't even know that they're doing this for a reason other than by their
own free will,
right?
Right.
That's what they think.
That's what you want them to think.
And again,
this is manipulation and I'm sorry about that.
The thing is,
is that you're manipulating for positive outcomes.
You're not manipulating for your own benefit.
You're not manipulating for D to make bad something bad happened,
that person,
you're influencing them so that they do a better jobs of the team does better so
that the mission gets accomplished.
Now I go on.
Creating adversarial or antagonistic relationships never helps you reach end
goals.
This is slightly related to the old.
Keep your friends close enemies closer.
People that outright oppose me will never help me and we'll usually maneuver to
hurt my cause.
This is never good.
At least a neutral relationship.
Seldom real results in someone actively sabotaging my efforts.
So it's really easy to get an adversarial relationships.
And that wasn't one of my little goto words that I used to use when talking to
my subordinate leadership.
What?
Add the theater,
your relationships,
you know,
I'd say,
Hey,
you're starting to get into an adversarial relationship with this person and
then where's that gonna go?
And I would say it's never going to be good.
They're never going to,
they're never going to go out of their way to help you.
In fact,
when you're an adversary of somebody,
they go out of their way to sabotage you and hurt you.
And that's,
that's just never going to be helpful.
So then I go on to say,
your history reveals that you are good at getting into adversarial situations.
You should work to control that impulse.
It will never help you attain your goals.
And that's the,
you know,
you're laughing because that's a very blunt statement,
right?
That's a very blunt statement.
Your history reveals that you are good at getting into adversarial situations.
Too.
Good at it though.
Like that's a skill.
Yeah,
you're real good at it.
Um,
and you can see this is,
this is pretty blunt,
uh,
pretty blunt writing here.
And the reason is because I had a relationship with this guy.
You know,
he was open to hear what I had to say.
And so it wasn't like I was just being a jerk and I was going to put them on the
defensive
and he knew that and he knew that I was always,
you know,
looking out for his best interests and I knew he would look out for mine as
well.
So we had a very good relationship
going on.
Don't burn bridges,
period.
Nothing is ever gained by this.
The future is never known.
And I always do what I can to keep lines of communication open bridges intact
and reinforced if possible.
So why burn bridges?
So seldom in life should you
burn a bridge?
And a lot of times people think,
because almost see you'll,
and I'm aggressive that I've,
I'm like this kind of burn bridges type of person.
Right.
And it's,
it's just not true because it's not an effective way to go through life.
Now I go on to make a note about that.
I don't like to say never,
but when dealing with human relationships,
which are inherently complex and the unpredictable,
I believe that you should never follow courses of action that can not be undone,
reversed or manipulated in the future.
Of course,
now I'm talking about you know,
people on the same team.
I'm not talking about,
you know,
going to war and there you obviously do things in war that are completely on
reversible because you're destroying and killing people and they're never coming
back.
So this is different.
This is,
this is in a team situation where you're trying to work together and you're,
you're in a leadership role
going on.
Believe in what you're saying,
but except that you might be wrong.
I believe in what I'm saying and if I don't it,
I study and question it until it makes sense or I change what I am saying until
I do believe it.
That's a little hard to understand.
That last piece.
So,
so what I'm saying is you've got to believe in what you're saying.
You have to believe in what you're saying.
And if you don't believe it,
then you've got either a question,
whatever it is that you're being told to believe or that you should believe that
you're supposed to believe.
You've got a question that until you understand it and then once you understand
it,
then you have belief in it.
And you know,
I,
I'm not going to go into crazy detail on that because in,
in our book that Leif and I wrote,
you know,
there's a chapter and it's called belief and it explains exactly what I'm
talking about when it comes to making sure that you believe in what you're
saying.
But I think the point that I was focused on here was more that sometimes you're
wrong and you have to be able to admit when you're wrong.
And I,
I go on to kind of go into some detail here if I'm wrong,
I look forward to admitting it because it gives the opportunity to advertise
being humble and open minded.
That's interesting.
And people miss that opportunity all the time.
When they're wrong,
they either put their foot down and deny it or they don't take advantage of the
fact that they got that,
that when they're wrong,
they say,
oh,
you know what,
Echo,
ah man,
I,
I'm definitely wrong here.
I think you had a much better idea.
Let's I'm stepping back and you run with it.
That's a great sign.
It makes people respect you and go,
yeah,
that's cool.
This guy,
this guy's humble enough to admit when he's wrong and they liked that.
So that's actually a form of manipulation in its own right,
because I want you to think that I'm humble and I am humbled,
but I want to make sure that you see that,
right.
I go on to tell this individual,
you are not good at being wrong or taking criticism.
This is a weakness of yours.
So recognize pool and again,
you can see the hear the,
that's where that kind of the relationship that I had with them comes out.
Right.
You really put that,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
that's real serious.
Real good.
And this is written,
I would say maybe eight years ago,
something like that.
So it's pretty old.
Thank God for computers because we have,
you know,
uh Huh.
Records of things,
right?
Right.
You saved it,
right?
Control F.
Yeah,
for sure.
Now I go on.
Think strategic.
You will win and lose daily battles all the time.
If you flaunt your victories,
which you do,
they hurt you strategically.
If you soak in your defeats,
which you also do,
it hurts you strategically.
This is wrong.
Winning in daily battles gives you the opportunity to deflect credit,
show your humbleness and victory and show your ability to lead,
which all help you in the longterm fight to achieve your goals.
Losing a battle gives you the opportunity to generous,
generously seed your position to admit you're wrong,
which both display,
humbleness and display your ability to follow.
So
people in every business and every job in in life,
in your house,
you win and lose little battles all the time and deciding which ones are worth
fighting for,
number one.
And then when you do win them,
how do you act?
And then when you lose them,
And all of these,
the winning and the losing is not as important as how you act upon winning or
losing and how you,
you continue to influence the situation.
Even though you might have lost,
you do it in such a way that you show humility and you open up,
you show your open mind and it makes the person,
you build your relationship with them.
So winning or losing is not important.
What's important is how you react to winning and losing.
Yeah.
Like when you,
um,
like when you say you're sorry,
right.
You know,
like if two people were in a relationship or even friends and get into an
argument,
fight,
whatever about whatever.
And uh,
in one person they don't want to say they're sorry,
you know,
because it'll show that I was wrong or it'll show that I lost the argument or
show that my points aren't valid or whatever they think.
Yeah.
But when you say sorry and ferreal say sorry,
don't be like,
well,
I'm sorry if you were offended.
Don't say that kind of stuff.
Don't be like,
okay,
I'm sorry.
Don't say like that.
Like really mean it and when you can do that,
it's consistently,
it'll be any future argument.
It'll start to break down that barrier of defense.
You know?
So the the person that people,
both of them won't go into it thinking,
okay,
I gotta,
I gotta Mount this defense against this person.
Now it can be little bit more of a fair problem solving situation more so than
this argument me against you,
because they trust they're not going to get attacked if if they show weakness or
whatever.
If they're like,
oh,
you know what?
I know I,
I made a mistake there.
They you demonstrate by saying,
sorry,
you demonstrated that you're not going to go and turn up the heat.
When they start showing that weakness,
it's like,
okay,
you can,
you can solve problems a lot more easy.
That's that's thinking strategic.
Right?
Right.
Speaking to people going on here,
speaking to people,
oh wait,
going back,
I say you have a bad tendency to get caught up in tactical battles.
You expend effort and ammunition,
receive wounds and tear yourself up when you should be straight thinking
strategically.
And that kind of goes to what you were just saying.
People will get all angry and they'll hurt the relationship.
Why?
Because they want to win this meaningless battle.
Meaningless battle,
so detached.
She
yourself.
When you start feeling that anger,
that aggression,
frustration,
detach
yourself and ask yourself,
what am I really arguing about?
What is happening right here?
Why am I getting worked up?
You probably shouldn't be.
Now go on to speaking to people will literally speaking to people,
treat everyone with respect from e one to Oh 10,
he will,
he won in the military is the lowest ranking person.
Oh 10 and officer 10 is the highest.
That would be an admiral or a general.
The e one is the,
is the seaman recruit,
uh,
the lowest ranking person.
What I'm saying?
Treat everyone with respect.
Speak with humility.
This disarms people and is one of the best forms of manipulation.
And again,
if everyone is is put off by that term manipulation,
which I know it is a very derogatory term and but you have to get over that
because you have to understand what I'm trying to say.
I'm trying to make sure that people understand that when you're in a leadership
position there's nicer ways of saying it,
but what you're trying to do is get people to do what you want them to do.
That's what leadership is.
And that's also what manipulation is.
Disarmed.
People are open to suggestion over confidence and condescending tone,
which is common for you,
causes defenses to go up and people to get defensive.
So w the minute you come in and you start being overconfident or talking to
people in a condescending manner,
they get defensive and all of a sudden they're not really listening.
That being said,
subtle confidence and believing in what you are saying as noted above,
allow people to also believe in what you are saying and that they trust in your
judgment and leadership,
however,
do not speak as if you know things your opponent does not.
That offends everyone,
especially seals.
So he never,
never like talk to people as if you know something that they don't.
You know,
because it offends people.
It offends me.
It offends everybody.
It's impossible not to be offended by that.
He makes you feel stupid.
You get defensive.
So what you've got to say things in a manner that you don't sound like I know it
and you don't.
Right?
Your rank means nothing in an argument.
Pulling rank in any way is defeat.
So the minute I have to say Echo,
I outrank you,
therefore I'm right means I means I couldn't.
It means my argument didn't make sense.
It should be able to stand on its own two feet.
And similar to that,
and this is something we,
we saw a lot in the seal teams and you see it a lot in the business world as
well.
It's similar to rank,
it's the experience,
it's pulling the experience card,
pulling the experience card is weak.
Arguments should be able to stand on their own without needing to be backed up.
By the way,
we did it in Baghdad,
the way we did it in Ramadi,
the way we did it in Afghanistan or whatever the case may be,
you shouldn't need to say that.
Now you can cite an example,
but that shouldn't be the basis of your argument.
And we see that in the business world where someone will say,
well,
we've been through this before,
right?
And well,
why did you go through it before then?
Why are we going through it again?
If you went through it before,
maybe you did something wrong,
but that's a tendency that people have,
and in the business world,
you end up with people that have been in a specific industry for 2030 40 years,
and so it's very easy for them just to fall back on the,
well,
this is the way we'd done it before.
I've seen this a million times.
I've always done it.
I've done this before.
I've been through this before.
You've heard all of these examples.
It's what people do.
Also like if people,
they're in some kind of debate or argument about,
I don't know,
whatever the solar system,
there'll be like,
oh,
I have a college degree.
Almost like my argument is better than yours regardless of what it is because I
have that college degree.
Yeah.
I have an example of that where a young seal was feeling as if he was being
disrespected about what?
That he didn't know very much.
He's a pretty new seal and he fell back on the argument of exactly what you just
said.
Well this was like,
you know,
I have an,
I have a degree in problem solving or something along mother.
I've been to classes on problem solving.
That was his reason why people should listen to them,
which is not a good card to pull out in any situation and definitely not in the
seal teams.
Hey,
I've been a client,
I've been to a class on problem solving.
You need to listen to me.
Wait a second,
why don't you just present your solution?
Right.
And then let it stand on its own two feet.
Because if you're so good at problem solving than we surely you must have a
wonderful solution.
Yeah,
you took that class for sure,
man.
Uh,
but yes,
it's the same thing.
So to close this thing out,
I said anyway,
those are some thoughts.
I've thought about this today.
After we had that conversation,
I left thinking about my principles of management leadership off the battlefield
in administrative situations.
These are the same principles I used in combat building relationships and
leading.
And I also use them in administrative leadership situations.
And as you know,
I've been successful in that environment as well.
You're a great leader.
Just make some adjustments to your game and you'll be even better.
And that's it.
That's how I close it out to this guy who was,
you know,
got this note from me and hit me back and said,
hey man,
thanks.
That's good stuff and I'll take action.
And definitely improved as game with it.
Now that's a pretty
nice counseling session or a nice attempt to help somebody.
Now,
this next example that I'm going to go through is somebody that was on his last,
he was in a leadership position and he was having some significant problems.
Now
he was an inexperienced guy and for some unknown reason,
he was cocky.
He was arrogant,
he was failing as a leader,
and he'd been through multiple verbal counselings like I talked about.
And you asked me,
do we write people up?
I mean,
the seal teams for,
for writing somebody up for a leadership problem.
They've been counselled numerous times verbally because you don't expect,
I mean,
it's not that hard,
you know,
it's not that hard to say,
hey,
make this adjustment.
The Guy Goes,
oh yeah,
okay.
I didn't see that I was doing that.
The only time you ended up with someone that you have to actually write it down
is when someone gets,
starts getting to a point where you say,
okay,
this person's job is now in jeopardy.
[inaudible] and this is,
uh,
again,
thanks to technology.
I,
I saved this to technology.
Yeah.
So here we go.
Seldom do I have to do this.
Most guys listen and adjust and get better and move on.
My cadre meaning that the training crew that I had,
my contrary and your leadership asked that I talked to you and it is my job and
my duty and my responsibility to try and make squared away.
Tactical seal leaders
know this.
I have personally worked with and seen all kinds of platoon commanders with all
kinds of personalities.
If you count my previous experience in platoons and training cell and as an
enlisted man,
the number is pretty big.
I've done seven deployments serving in every spot from the youngest e three new
guy to the oldest and the task unit commander.
That being said,
I'm not that good at anything but I am a hard worker.
I don't like to waste my time with people that don't appear to have the desire
to be better seals and you don't appear to have a desire to improve yourself
despite your history,
which includes the following,
getting bad FITREPs.
So fit reps is short for fitness reports and that's basically an evaluation.
And this guy had really bad evaluations,
just like general evaluation.
Not yet.
His stuff,
well,
it's fitness.
Fitness is like one block,
but there'll be a block on leadership.
There'll be a block on tactical knowledge,
there'll be there.
So there's all these blocks in his,
and he had bad fitness reports,
bad evaluations,
getting sent to a staff bill it as a junior officer.
So they took him and instead of making him and putting him in a seal platoon,
they had them in some administrative job,
which is a big signal.
Sometimes they'll do that in between tours or after you do an assistant platoon
commander tour,
they'll give you a tour like that to expand your knowledge.
But he just got put straight into that.
So that wasn't good.
And finally having a horrible reputation in the teams,
which this individual certainly did have.
No,
I go on and say,
I didn't take this into account when looking at you as a seal officer and as a
man,
I don't care what people say,
I judge people on what I see with my own eyes.
At first I thought you were just in another Alpha male seal that rubs people the
wrong way.
No big deal.
There are plenty of seals like that.
I usually like them.
Most of my true friends fall into that category and that was one of the things
about this guy,
you know,
he was like a big guy and he was pretty aggressive and
I thought to myself,
just what I said,
I thought,
okay,
you know what?
Maybe he's rubbing people the wrong way and,
and people are a little intimidated by that.
As time passed,
I began to see something different.
This is what I see.
You are insecure about something.
I don't know what,
but it forces you to act arrogant and chrome across as selfish.
Your performance as a tactical leader varies between below average and average
with some visible spikes of increased potential.
You almost incapable of communicating with other people respectfully.
So those top three right there for whatever reason to that,
and I never figured out what made this individual so insecure.
I don't know if he,
I,
I'd have no idea.
I don't know what happened to them,
but it's okay.
We have insecurities,
we get intimidated.
We feel like we have to over prove ourselves.
It's okay,
these things happen.
You just make adjustments.
That's all you gotta do.
You gotta make some adjustments.
You gotta realize that you're not communicating with people respectfully.
And when somebody tells you that you're not,
you got a question,
what do I sound like?
Maybe you pull out of of a recorder and listen to yourself.
You have some good ideas,
you have some good ideas from time to time,
but you act as if you know everything all the time.
Your ability to elevate your presence to that of a respected leader of men on
the battlefield and in garrison is almost nonexistent.
And I don't know if at this time I was really using the term like detach that
much,
but that's what I was trying to get across to him is that he wasn't able to
elevate his presence.
He wasn't able to come across like a leader.
He was right there in mentally with the rest of the platoon
going on.
You cannot mask your emotions and you don't understand the ramifications of that
shortfall.
So these are the little things.
The little eye roll.
The heavy sigh.
Yeah,
the crossed arms.
I just,
all these
little things that it was like,
it was like an open book when you'd see this guy,
you knew exactly what he was thinking and he had no idea that it was so obvious
to everybody else.
Myself,
all the rest of my instructor staff,
his leadership,
everyone was thinking the same thing and in his mind he,
he was good to go.
He was,
you know,
he was a stone face poker player.
Yeah.
And he kind of gets worse when you can't mask your emotions,
but your emotions are reflective of your insecurity,
which you mentioned is one of the first things.
So it's like this double whammy.
It's one thing if you can mask your emotions,
but you're pretty humble in,
in general and you're a nice guy or whatever your though with kind of,
yeah.
And the,
the emotions that you're not masking or something positive.
That's great.
Psalm positive
or,
or a lot of puzzles,
maybe some negative,
but hey look,
no one's perfect kind of thing.
But yeah,
if it's just like insecurity oozing out of
yeah,
that'd be any insecurity was really the,
what oozed out of him was I know everything you don't know.
Look,
Jocko,
I know you've been in the teams for 18 years and you done multiple deployments
overseas and even though I have done zero deployments overseas,
I know more than you.
Yeah.
Uh,
here we go on and,
and so now I start trying to make sure I cover all the bases with this guy.
Sure.
You do not have the understanding of human nature,
team building,
leadership,
influence,
manipulation,
compromise and the broad concepts of tactical operation,
operational and strategic leadership and management.
Perhaps you don't have the intellect to understand these things because if you
did,
why are we sitting here right now talking about this?
And by the way,
the reason this is written down,
I wrote it down and then brought him into my office,
put it in front of him,
and then read it to him because I wanted to be crystal clear.
And so that's why this is written in that perspective.
Them saying,
why are we sitting here talking about it right now?
Why am I not thinking this might not be the most polished guy in the world,
but he's a good guy and he'll get things done because you're gonna end up with
plenty of seals that are just,
they're just not that polished or they're a little rough around the edges or
they can't brief well or whatever.
I mean,
it's cool.
There's,
there's all kinds of different guys in the seal teams and you just gotta take
what you get and you,
you strengthen your weaknesses a little bit.
But this guy was just not getting there
for some reason.
You believe that you are a victim,
that people don't like you or have it out for you.
And this was so weird,
this guy had this attitude that everyone wanted to fire him,
that everyone was against him.
And he was this,
he was in this,
you know,
struggle on his own against the world.
And it was just completely not true,
especially in the beginning.
I mean,
obviously it escalated to that,
but that he brought it upon himself.
But,
but honestly that's something I kind of,
I kind of pride in,
in as a leader in taking a,
a blank slate when I meet somebody and saying,
okay,
cool.
You know,
hey look,
this guy has a bad reputation or whatever.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna see what I can do with them.
I want to make them better.
I kind of take pride in that and want to make people better.
And so for him to think that I was out to get him to this training cadre was out
to get him.
Oh,
it was just not true.
Just completely not true.
Uh,
this is not true,
but it isolates you,
hurts your ability to interact with people and keeps you in a paranoid,
guarded and confrontational state.
It's,
it's a rough,
rough
next.
You don't understand the broad skills required to be a good seal leader such as
tact,
teambuilding communications and trust building.
So it's interesting.
None of this is about fire maneuver.
None.
This is about taking down a building.
None of this is about,
you know,
how to,
how to plan and execute and assault.
None of this is about that because that stuff is relatively easy to do and what
we would,
99.9% of the time when we fire a leader,
it had nothing to do with their tactical prowess.
It had to do with them as a leader.
Now them as a leader effect would effect the tactical outcome of operations for
sure,
but that wouldn't be the,
the key component of their failings.
The key component of their failings would be they're arrogant.
What's
going on.
You do not understand the burden of command.
You do not understand the influence you have on your men.
This is a big one.
This is one of those ones that I,
I find this with CEOs,
I find this with mid level managers.
I find this with everyone where they don't understand their influence on their
people.
They understand when they say something off the cuff that everybody listens and
they think they mean it and it has real impact on people.
They don't understand when they show up late now being laid as okay when they go
home early.
Going home early is okay.
Those were the little things,
examples of little things that people don't understand the influence they have
on their troops
going on.
You do not understand the gift you've been honored with to lead men in combat
against our nation's sworn enemies.
My concern is how you will act overseas when lives are at stake.
I cannot allow you to go forward with these shortfalls.
Okay?
And that is something that
in the seal teams,
so in the seal teams,
people think,
well,
if someone's no good,
you just fire them.
That's it.
And it's actually not true.
You know,
you have to have good reason and document what issues they're having.
And the other thing is that that's really harsh about firing someone in the seal
teams is when you fire someone in the seal teams,
you're ruining their life.
It's their dream to be a seal.
Now they're not gonna be CEO anymore.
Their paycheck,
their retirement.
I mean,
they've got plans,
they,
they're counting on this.
So when you fire someone in the seal teams,
it,
it can be devastating career blow and it can really ruin someone's life.
Now,
there are times where we go,
hey,
you know what,
this guy's going to be okay.
We need to push him back a little while when you recycle and he'll be able to
come back and he'll get better and he just needs to learn more if that happens
as well.
But in this type of situation,
this guy was already with a bad reputation.
This was going to be,
if he got fired from this job,
this was going to be a death sentence for his career.
So when you fire someone from the seal teams,
they're not out of the military there or it is on the situation?
Yeah,
sometimes they they'll get,
it's a lot of times the officers will be removed from the military.
The enlisted guys might go to the regular navy,
which is,
which is a harsh punishment for a guy that's been in the seal teams that you in
the seal teams,
you have quite a bit of freedom.
You get more money,
you doing some job that you really like and then all of a sudden you're not
doing a job that you really like.
And that can be a severe form of punishment as well.
Is it,
is it like going to the miners from the major league baseball?
It's just,
it's just a totally different job.
It's like going from baseball to something completely different.
I mean it's going from baseball to do an accounting,
you know,
or from baseball to going to construction.
You know,
cause the regular navy has regular jobs that are like that.
There's accounting jobs,
there's building jobs,
there's you know,
technique,
technical jobs.
So it's like going from a job that's like a sport,
which is the seal teams going into a job.
That's more of a job.
But it's not like a dishonorable discharge situation.
No,
not unless the guys,
and you know,
it's interesting,
I remember I was on a,
I was on the ship one time and
the waves were big and it was cold and we were launching off this ship in the
middle of the night.
And there was this regular navy guy,
FirstClass Bosens mate,
which means,
you know,
he ran the,
the deck operations of the ships and putting boats in the water and,
and it was all stormy and dark.
And we're on these little boats out in the middle of the ocean.
We're about to go launch.
And,
uh,
the guy says to me,
man,
I would never want your job.
And that's,
you know,
that's what he was thinking.
And I look back at him and I said,
well,
that's good cause I would never want years either because I would never want to
be stuck on a ship and doing that kind of work.
But it's,
we both had jobs that we liked.
You know,
it,
everyone's got jobs they like,
but so when a person's in the seal teams though,
and they're getting put to a job,
it's normally a job that they don't really like.
Uh,
and what my point in all of that is that it is difficult to ruin someone's
career and it is a heavy burden when you have to do this to somebody.
That being said,
you're going to send these people,
especially a person in a leadership position,
they're going to be overseas and responsible for people's lives.
You have got to do the right thing.
Yeah.
And I say that to business leaders now,
you know,
you've got to do everything you can to mentor someone and that's,
that's,
that's actually how I know you've done everything you can to mentor and get
someone along.
Because when you fire them,
you shouldn't feel guilty about it.
And when,
when a leader says all really,
I feel bad about firing this person,
okay,
then that means you haven't done everything you can to mentor them.
Because if you have and they still fail,
then they're incapable of doing the job and they need to go find a different
job.
But then you get put in different positions.
That's just the facts.
Right.
But if you've done everything you've can and they can't do it,
then yeah,
they need to move on.
But when you go,
oh,
I'd feel,
feel bad about getting rid of this person,
it's cause you,
cause you haven't had this conversation that I'm having with this guy right
here.
The laying it out and saying here's what you're doing wrong,
here's how you need to fix it.
This is what the expectations are.
And if you don't meet them,
you're not going to be here.
You need to clearly understand that.
Yeah.
It really puts it into perspective.
Right on that last item there one,
when you said my concern is how you would act overseas when lives are at stake,
like that really puts it into perspective for,
I mean really looking at it in a lighthearted kind of way.
You can kind of compare this to let's say,
you know when you're in kindergarten you get a report card or whatever and then
at the end if you're a kid like this guy,
Yup.
You get a little note at the end says does the all it does not play well with
others.
Right.
And you're like,
all right.
You know,
he doesn't know an easy whatever this,
especially when this is the adult version of that,
but times it by like 10 and it sums it up right here with that last one,
like when lives are at stake
and that's exactly what was going on.
So here I tried to give this guy corrective measures is what I called it,
corrective measures.
Number one,
be humble.
And we get asked all the time,
what's the most important characteristic of a leader and Lafe and I will say all
the time,
humility.
And
if you're not humble,
then how can you look at yourself and say,
I need to do stuff better.
How can you look at your team and say,
we need to get better.
How can you look at your enemy and say,
I better respect them.
[inaudible] if you don't have that humility,
you're gonna fail there.
So my first corrective action to this guy,
be humble.
Number two,
truly and deeply accept the fact that you have some serious personality defects
that you need to immediately put in check and over the longterm completely fix.
So always very concerned that this guy was going to sit there and nod his head.
Yup,
okay,
Yup.
Sorry,
but not truly and deeply except the fact that he had these issues because
there's a big difference between non your head and saying,
I got you sir.
Okay,
sir.
Yep.
Yes sir.
Oh,
I'm gonna.
I'm going to do better.
There's a big difference between that and going home,
looking in the mirror and saying,
I've got some serious problems that I need to fix
going on.
Understand that the criticism you are hearing from me is not mine alone,
but also my staffs and your leadership's as well.
I've also heard this from other people outside your command.
Your reputation is horrible.
Again,
I wanted to make sure that he didn't think this was just Jocko being hostile.
I wanted him to realize it was my entire staff and his leadership that was being
hostile,
going on corrective measure,
embrace and contemplate the solemn responsibility of being a seal officer about
to lead men into battle and possibly to their deaths
and brace.
The burden of command.
This is one that for me,
me
was very disturbing to see because I had lead men into battle and I had
had my guys get killed.
So to have him with this attitude where I could see that didn't occur in his
brain,
he didn't understand that these guys that he's supposed to be in charge of,
he's going to be asking them to do things that can get them killed.
And I don't think he understood that.
Hmm.
The burden of command,
that's the burden of command.
That's that heavy responsibility.
Yes.
In combat it means guys getting wounded or getting killed,
and that is a heavy burden.
But I will tell you in the business world,
when you've got people's jobs at stake,
when you've got the profitability or the survival of a company at stake,
and
dozens or hundreds or thousands of people may or may not have a job,
if you don't do your job correctly as a leader,
that is a heavy burden as well.
Hmm.
Going on,
be the best at everything you do
in doing that
one.
Put everyone else before yourself.
Push away compliments.
Shift them to your peers and your men,
except responsibility of failure and shortfalls.
Only foreign in them
is the improvement and growth.
So this is actually a conversation we had on one of our earlier podcasts.
Any compliments success,
you shift that to your peers and your men and you're accepted responsibility for
the failures and the shortfalls.
And again,
if you don't accept the responsibility for those failures and shortfalls,
how are they ever going to get fixed?
The answers,
they're not.
I'm never going to change everything.
Anything.
If it's all echo's fault,
I did everything right.
It's all echo's fault.
Yeah.
Okay.
Truly listen and try to understand what people tell you by first understanding
that your personal compass is wrong,
truly and completely wrong for what is right and wrong for what a good seal and
a bad one is for what makes an exceptional leader and a horrible one.
You must correct this compass so that it may guide you in the right direction.
Yeah.
And my point with this was that I think in his mind,
his vision of what a quote unquote good seal was.
I think he thought he was being [inaudible].
And I had to explain to him that he was wrong.
He did not understand what a good seal was.
He did not understand what an exceptional leader was.
He just did not understand it.
You must correct this compass so that it may guide you in the right direction,
the final
okay
corrective measure,
lose your ego.
This guy,
despite having
eight treacherous record and a horrible reputation despite that for some unknown
reason,
but I cannot fathom he had a big ego.
He thought he was a great seal.
He thought because he was a big dude and could shoot well,
he's a,
he was a talented athlete as well,
but he thought that that made him a good seal
and it didn't.
It just gave him a big ego.
So
now I tell them,
these are tall tasks,
but you control them all.
And that's true.
If you look at every one of those things,
be humble.
Yes,
he controls that.
Except the fact that he needs some serious work.
Yes.
He controls that.
Understand that the criticism is coming from a bunch of people,
not just me.
Yes.
That's under his control.
Embracing,
contemplate the solemn responsibility of being a seal officer about to lead men
into battle and possibly to their deaths.
Yes.
He controls that ability.
Be the best at everything you do.
Yes.
That's under his control,
so all these things lose your ego.
These are all things that he had control over.
We need good aggressive leaders in the seal teams.
We don't need the person that I outlined above,
and the reason I pointed that out is because I think in this guy's mind,
he was an aggressive guy
and he was a good leader in his mind,
but I wanted him to know that,
yes,
we do need aggressive leaders in the seal teams,
but we don't need this guy.
We don't need the guy that I'm just talking about.
It's in your hands.
Good luck.
Then I asked him,
do you have any questions or comments for me?
Which he did not.
I asked him,
are you sure?
He was sure.
I asked him if he understood and he nodded his head.
And again,
the reason I'm reading these because these are my actual notes.
Okay.
And then I said,
do you believe I am right or do you just think I don't or do you think I just
don't get it and that you actually know what's up?
And He of course said,
no,
I understand.
And even as you were saying on those words,
yeah,
I was not convinced.
And
this gentleman did not make it in his leadership role and he ended up getting
fired
when he said he bet he understands.
Was it like,
was he all salty?
Like you understand and no,
I mean he was,
he was not destroyed.
He was not openly disrespectful and maybe somewhere in his brain he was trying
to understand,
trying to listen
and trying to believe,
but
the,
it,
it wasn't there.
Okay.
So in going through this,
and I think one of the reasons why I wanted to do this on the podcast was
a lot of times leadership is about awareness.
And
I use this example all the time in the movie terminator,
it says,
you know,
in the year 2016 the machines became aware and I used to get to see that with cu
leaders like they,
they become aware of being in a leadership position.
And so that's,
that's one form of awareness.
And I think a lot of times
you don't recognize,
if you're not aware of something,
you can't recognize what the problem is.
And so going through this,
all these issues that this guy had,
I people that are listening to this podcast,
you don't have all these issues.
It's impossible.
You wouldn't even like to listen to this podcast because this is a podcast where
we're all kind of sitting here taking ourselves apart and seeing what we could
do better and trying to learn and,
and people with,
with this type of attitude that this guy had,
they,
they don't even enjoy this because they think they know everything.
Yup.
You're not even talking to them.
I'm not even thought out,
but everybody,
myself included,
I still go through this and I go,
I'm doing that a little bit right there.
I'm falling into that trap.
I'm getting a little bit arrogant on this thing.
I'm doing this wrong.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I'm letting my emotions out too much.
And again,
I'm not telling people to be robots,
but you can't be an emotional disaster or emotional show for your people.
So show that awareness and thinking about it.
And the other thing,
this is the other reason why I wanted to use this particular note is because I
think it's as direct of a note.
I could write someone,
maybe I could do better now,
I don't know.
But at the time to go face to face with someone and kind of call them out.
This is about as stern as I could do it.
And this is the standard that we need to hold ourselves to that sternness of
that.
What am I doing wrong and how do I be honest with myself and be my own worst
critic,
which is a big cliche,
but yeah,
be your own worst critic.
Look at yourself and you can't be your own worst critic if you don't detach from
the situation.
If you're inside your own head,
you can't even critique yourself.
So you got to get out of that brain.
And that's going to be a common theme for not just for this show,
not just for this podcast but forever.
Cause it's one of those things.
It's really helped me and I think has helped the people that I've worked with
when they,
when they overcome that.
So there's some counseling
for everybody,
myself included.
So now we are looking into the Internet questions.
So again,
if you're listening to this podcast and you're wondering where these questions
come from,
they come from a couple of different places on the Internet.
Facebook,
I actually get most of them from Twitter.
Um,
you,
if you want to see what's happening on Twitter with me,
it's at Jocko Willink.
If you want to see what's happening on Twitter with Echo,
it's at Echo Charles.
And if you wanna see what's happening on there.
And also if you want to submit questions,
then for me Twitter is the place to do it because I can jump on there you,
that means you have to be disciplined and keep your question short.
And I just dragged those questions out of there and and put them into the well
of questions.
And
with that
in some of my answer,
you know right there on the spot and some of them I go,
Ooh,
that's a good topic.
So with that in mind and,
and I'll tell you,
this is still from the well of questions where most of these,
I don't have the name of the person cause I'm still on the well of questions of
the first time I asked and I got hundreds of questions.
So I'm still going through those.
And here we go.
What drove you to become an English major in college?
This is something I surprisingly get asked a lot.
And I guess it shouldn't be that surprising because if you don't know my story
with college,
I was actually already in the seal teams.
I had spent 10 years in the seal teams.
When I finally got sent to college,
I had to get a college degree in order to continue my career as a seal officer.
And when I went to college,
it was not even a question that I was going to be an English major.
So why is that?
Well,
luckily I'd spent enough time in the seal teams to realize that the most
important skill from an officer perspective that could differentiate and make
you do a better job of something you can,
I mean we talk about leadership all the time and,
and the different points and humility and discipline,
all those things that make you a good leader,
that's great.
But those aren't things that you learned in college.
So which skill could I learn in college that will actually make me do a better
job as a seal leader?
And I knew before I even showed up there and exactly what
that was going to be in that was English.
Why?
Well,
English to me was the study of the English language.
The English language is the methodology that we,
American humans use to communicate with each other.
And as a leader it is critical that you have a good control and a good grip on
this medium that you're going to use to communicate what your vision is,
what your ideas are,
what your strategies are,
what the orders are.
You have to be able to do that in clear and concise language.
And I knew that English would provide me with that.
You also have to be able to understand what you are being told to do or what the
orders are or what the mission is or things like rules of engagement.
So rules of engagement as a legal document written by lawyers and you have to
read it and understand it.
And I found that this was very,
very useful.
This was probably,
and again looking back,
cause you know what,
I guess I could have gotten a degree in history and I could have really drilled
down in the military and that would've been helpful as well.
But the practical application of English in that job was very important.
And I will tell you that in anyone that's gonna end up in a leadership position,
the command of the English language is a very important thing.
And when I started to get into Shakespeare
and Shakespeare,
no,
there's at least half the audience just went,
Oh God,
what is he talking about?
Shakespeare.
The thing about Shakespeare's,
and this is what I had to learn in college,
when you first see Shakespeare,
you think,
oh,
I don't understand this you,
this is a bunch of Gobbledygook.
This doesn't sound like English.
I don't understand it.
You're not supposed to understand it.
And people don't pick up a Shakespeare play and just understand it.
You have to study what the words mean.
The guy made up words,
he just made them up.
So how could you know what it means?
You're lying if you say,
you know what I mean?
Is He made it up.
He used archaic words that,
or words back then that weren't archaic,
but there are archaic now and people do not use them anymore.
So how could you know what they mean?
You don't.
You have to look them up and figure out what they mean.
And that was very good for me to take a bunch of Shakespeare and have to look at
these,
look at this writing and figured out what it all means.
Because I realized that when three years later,
four years later,
when I got a rules of engagement that was written by a lawyer,
and there was words in there I didn't understand,
I didn't just go,
Oh God,
I don't understand this and throw it away.
No.
I said,
okay,
there's a word.
Understand.
I just need to look it up,
figure out what it means and make sense of it.
And that's what,
that's what studying Shakespeare specifically did for me.
And you know,
at some point we're going to get into some Shakespeare right here.
And there's some very,
very powerful
things that Shakespeare wrote,
which are unmatched in language,
in my opinion.
So that's down the road.
Probably not too far,
but that is why I studied English in college.
How do you deal with delayed onset muscle soreness or stiffness from weight
training?
And how does it affect your Jujitsu?
Uh,
the Jujitsu questions.
Awesome.
So
obviously I work out,
I work out pretty much every day I work out,
that means I lift weights,
I do calisthenics,
I do sprints,
I do some kind of physical conditioning every single day.
And that means that yes,
I am always at least somewhat sore and tired when I show up to train the
Jujitsu,
which I usually do in the evenings.
So for me,
Jujitsu always makes me feel better.
You know,
you're,
you're basically getting a very gnarly full body massage.
When you train in Jujitsu,
you're getting a very aggressive and involuntary full body massage and you're
getting stretched in different directions.
So whenever,
you know,
if I did some exercise that made me sore,
if I did dead lifts and I'm feeling sore,
tied to my back and I go do Jujitsu,
by the time it's done,
I don't feel that soreness anymore.
So just like a massage or a stretch,
I think it,
it,
um,
loosens you up and,
and it's pretty normal for me.
I also like to train sore and tired because it just makes training a little bit
harder and makes you more ready.
And all that being said,
when I do heavy squats or high repetition squats or any squats where I kind of
pushed the envelope,
yeah my legs are really sore and it sucks to get on the mat and I do it anyways.
And,
and also the training,
while your muscles are sore,
when you're tired,
it helps your technique.
Right.
So you're not in trouble.
She has a bigger guy.
Yup.
You know,
having strengthened weight at the same time as an advantage can be used as a
weapon but can get in the way of your technique.
They can get new techniques and he can't get in the way of your progression and
progress.
Yes,
for sure.
Um,
you might be speaking from a standpoint of someone who is in good condition by
the way.
Cause I would say that for most people,
I would argue
for most people it's not a full body
massage.
It doesn't loosen you up.
It makes you more sore.
Yes.
And you know what,
that's a good point.
And beyond the fact this is,
you actually are right on more points than you know,
because beyond the fact that yes,
I am in fairly good condition because I do work out every day.
Also Jujitsu from me because I am experienced is generally not a 100% physical
war like you have when you're not quite as experienced.
Right.
And if you watched you,
you know,
when I'm rolling with guys,
all my training partners,
they're all good guys too.
So we're,
we're training for,
you know,
an hour and we can do it.
It's not because we're that much better condition,
it's just that we're that got much more relaxed or we're relying more on
techniques.
So,
so that's a good point.
And I could see where in the early days,
now that being said,
I trained this way the whole time that I've trained.
So I even when I was a spazz crazy,
you know,
white belt warrior,
I still worked out every day and when I was a blue belt training,
super hard,
I still worked out everyday.
So you're,
I was going down the path that you are right.
But now I'm going to renege on that and say that you're wrong and you just need
to work out and get on the mat,
loosen it up and keep trading.
Well yeah,
I think in the grand scheme of things you'd be more loose.
Yeah,
but we're talking about delayed onset muscle soreness I think.
I think I would argue that most people after training Jujitsu,
unless it is like just a light like role.
But if you're,
you know,
if you're doing just,
I don't know,
your normal Jujitsu guy,
let's say he does for around six minutes,
one minute in between [inaudible]
he's going to get more delayed onset muscle soreness the next day from the
Jujitsu.
I don't think so.
I think so.
This is a issue that will not be solved on the Jocko podcast.
I would say try it.
Try it.
That's what I'm saying.
I think so.
Cause I've been trying it for years and years so we're going to go ahead.
Another thing is every time you show up to do Jujitsu,
it's not a competition day.
You know,
and not that you don't have roles and good roles and you go hard,
but there is a difference between like,
oh,
I'm going to let this guy pass my guard or I'm going to,
I'm going to hang on with every little piece of might.
And what does this look you're giving me right now?
I agree with you,
but it still doesn't change my argument that even if you're rolling that way
yet,
I think that you have to roll pretty light to not get any delayed onset muscle.
Okay,
and here's one more story and this is where,
this is where you might be,
right?
This is a funny story.
So like I just talked about when I went to college.
So when I went to college at the University of San Diego,
it was,
I was still in the military,
but I was,
my job was to go to college,
which meant that for somebody that was used to working 18 hours a day as a seal,
all of a sudden I didn't have 18 hours a day to work.
So I trained a lot.
And one of the things I noticed one day,
for whatever reason I had,
I think I had one of my kids was born and I had final exams or just some,
some perfect storm of events.
And I missed and I didn't train Jujitsu for three days.
And on the fourth day I got up out of bed and I felt all the like young and I
wasn't sore and I just,
I,
I was Dang,
I feel great.
What does this,
and knew what it was was that I hadn't trained.
And at that time,
at that time,
we,
this is when Dean lister and I were training like mad men and he was constantly
competing.
I was competing and he was,
and we would train for two to four hours a day of just cycle rolling.
And,
but again,
even when we were doing cycle rolling like that,
it wasn't competition day and,
but we,
but it definitely made me sore.
Yeah.
And so you do get some soreness.
You're,
you're correct.
I think I'm just used to being in a continued state of,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what it is.
So when you're like,
oh yeah,
I didn't roll for three days on that front end of that,
fourth day you woke up and you're like,
Dang,
I feel young.
What is this?
That's called rest.
You rested and you recovered.
It happens.
Agriculture,
apple now.
And there'll be days obviously days when I don't get to train.
Okay.
So this question is,
um,
it,
I don't know if it's an addition to the other question,
but it's phrased like this also,
I'd like to hear more,
but more about your writing process.
Tough Times.
What worked well,
creative breakthroughs.
Is that true?
I don't think these were related.
I think this is just pulled out,
so,
oh,
right,
right.
Okay.
Creative breakthroughs.
Yeah.
So first of all,
if to go specifically on how I wrote this book,
and you could probably apply this to any kind of task that you're looking at
doing,
but the first thing we did,
and Leif and I wrote this book together,
the first thing we did was we outlined the book and what the chapters were about
and what the stories inside the chapters.
So we both knew what the chapter was and then we said,
and if you haven't read the book,
I wrote half the chapters and he wrote half the chapters,
so we didn't,
we didn't write it together and try and mind meld the whole thing.
Now the intro we wrote together in the outro or whatever it's called,
we wrote it together and that was cool.
You know,
we just edited it because it was both of us talking,
but we didn't have to try and mind meld or or come to agreement on the rest of
it.
We just wrote separate chapters.
And so what I did was once we,
we knew what the chapters were,
once we knew what they were going to be about,
then I wrote a thousand words a day no matter what that was.
My,
I was very busy at the time,
was doing some big contracts.
I was super busy and I knew that I had to do it in chunks.
And I also know that my attention span is I can force it,
but it's not fun.
So a thousand words took me about an hour,
like 50 minutes to an hour.
So every day,
no matter what,
I sat down and I,
I ended up writing about 60,000 words.
So it took me,
I think it was 55,000 words,
took me 55 days,
55 days straight in my draft was done.
And that's,
that's,
there's a couple of good advantages to it.
Number one,
when you write every day,
if you write,
if you skip two days and then you'd go back,
guess what?
You've got to go back and reread what you wrote because you don't remember it.
Whereas if you just go back into it,
I could just pick up where I left off.
Boom.
I could start writing again an hour later,
I'm done.
Don't have to waste any time.
I have to go back and reread.
I know what my train of thought was.
That's important thing.
Mental.
So,
so that was important.
And sometimes I didn't feel like writing of course,
but I just wrote anyways.
And sometimes it would come out not that great,
but it doesn't matter.
You've got a thousand words that you can hone and you can adjust and you can
turn it into something good in.
And also it just takes away every excuse is gone.
There's no excuse.
There's no excuses.
There's only you do what you're supposed to do.
That's the only thing.
Not,
I'm don't know what to think.
I um,
I'm,
I lost my train of thought.
I have writer's block or whatever.
I'm too tired.
No,
it's like one answer for all these problems.
And that is right.
So you've got writer's block.
Good,
right?
You got A,
I'm too tired.
I had a long day.
Good.
Right.
Oh,
I'm stuck.
And I don't know where to take this story.
Good.
Right.
That's the only,
it's just one answer.
Solved every problems.
And that's kind of the same thing with,
with everything,
you know,
with going to the gym.
You know what,
I'm tired.
Good.
Go work out.
I'm sore.
Good.
Go work out.
I'm super busy right now.
Good.
Go workout.
You could do this,
you can apply this to any sort of,
you know,
with training,
Jujitsu.
I Dunno if I'm,
I'm,
I'm not feeling like my a game tonight.
Good.
Go train when you're weak.
Right.
Good.
Go train when you're mentally not,
not there because it doesn't matter.
What is it?
Is it the world championships today?
And even if it is the world championships,
you got to go fight anyways because it's the world championships.
So get on the mat and train.
Yeah,
you can,
you can
look at these when you say that,
that applies to everything.
Like you don't feel like it or whatever.
A lot of times create like creative block and I'm just realizing,
right when you said that this is the first time,
I'm kind of understanding this and realizing that,
okay,
when you have a creative block,
that's almost like
in my experience,
it's a good reason to not do creative stuff cause I can't because creativity
comes from a real,
like you have to feel it,
you have to want to do it.
It's like a creative thing.
Inspirado
yeah.
Or you cannot,
you manufacture Inspirado tech quote.
Tenacious D.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
You can't,
you know,
get me back on any,
whenever it's brought up.
So,
you know,
it's different than going to the gym.
So are you saying though,
if you get creative block,
and for those of you who don't know,
Echo Does v writes and produces and films and directs videos of all kinds.
So you're saying when you can't think of what to write,
you just stop.
Yes,
we have a queer in our meds,
you know what I'm saying is,
and that's okay.
I mean we all different techniques.
My,
my technique is not better than your technique.
Your technique may work.
Sometimes it may be work 100% for you.
I'm talking about my technique and my technique was like,
okay,
I've got writer's block.
I don't know where to go with this.
I'm going to write anyways.
Right,
and what you're saying is when that happens to you,
you say,
you know what,
I'm just going to walk away from it right now and come back to it later and
that's okay.
I see it until right now though.
I just realized that when you said,
okay,
if you don't feel like writing or good do it anyway because I guess I never
really thought past that because when you say,
yeah,
you'll just have more stuff to hone into.
Okay.
If later on when you do hit inspiration,
which now you have more material to draw inspiration from,
it's going to come clear like,
okay,
that thing that I wrote or you know,
put in when I wasn't inspired the,
okay,
that's got to go,
but you can learn so much from what you put down there.
Why doesn't that work?
Or,
Dang,
that was pretty good when I was feeling bored at when I was feeling whatever.
That's pretty good.
I'm gonna use that,
you know?
So you're gonna,
you're gonna get way more results potentially than you would if you simply don't
do anything and wait.
And what if the inspiration doesn't come back,
which she'd flocking doesn't a lot of the time,
then it's too late.
So yeah.
Good lesson learned right there.
Thanks.
That is a good one.
So next question from Jennifer from Jennifer.
This one I put in there that has a name.
Nice.
Jennifer.
Jennifer says,
I'm really struggling with focus lately.
I'd love for you to cover it on the podcast.
Focus cover that this is,
do we get asked this a lot about focus?
I don't know if we've got last specifically.
Yeah.
Specifically about focus,
but this is one of those things,
and this is,
this is I'm starting to realize a underlying theme with a lot of,
with a lot of what people are asking me and
yeah,
that is,
I think people have a vision or a thought that I am.
I've got some answer that is like,
Oh,
you didn't lack focus,
follow steps one,
two and three and I've talked about this with leadership and then I've got some
easy button solution for these situations.
And this got me thinking about my kids and one of my daughters who when she was,
I don't know what,
how old you are when you're supposed to learn the times tables,
but she was that age and she got really disappointed because she didn't know our
times tables and she would actually,
you're young.
When I,
again,
I don't,
I forget the grade,
but it's,
you know,
it's like maybe second grade,
third grade,
second,
third grade.
So she supposed to know her times tables,
she doesn't know him and she starts getting this,
this negative attitude of I'm stupid.
You know,
I'm dumb.
Other kids know them.
I don't know him.
And I just said,
oh well have you studied them?
And she hadn't,
she hadn't studied them.
She'd sat in class when they would go over to them and she'd picked up 50 or 60
or maybe even 70% of them.
But you know,
there's some hard ones in there,
right?
12 Times 1212 times 12 is a tough one.
You know,
there's some tricky ones in there that she didn't know.
And so I said,
oh well you need to study them and then you'll know them.
So you know,
we made the flash cards and she studied them and all of a sudden she knew him
and then she realized that you have to practice these things and you have to put
effort into them.
And it's the same thing with sports.
No,
you'll get the kid that says,
I'm not any good at baseball.
We've,
you don't spend any time practicing it.
And so it's the same thing with focus.
You,
it takes effort.
You just don't,
I don't wake up in the morning,
flip a switch,
and then become focused.
When I was writing,
when I was just talking about writing this,
this book that we wrote,
I didn't go,
okay,
flip the switch for focus.
I'm going to do a thousand words right now.
No,
no.
I had to,
I did sit down and go,
okay,
listen,
idiot,
this is your job.
You need to do it,
get it done.
You know another,
another funny story is in the seal teams we have these helmets where we had
them,
we've modified them since,
but had these helmets and underneath the helmets you would wear this,
this headset that your radio headphones would go into some.
When you're in the seal teams,
you're out on the battlefield.
You got to talk to different people and you've got to have a radio and you've
got nice almost,
I guess it would be to describe it.
It's like a Bose noise canceling headset for all practical purposes,
but it's durable and you wear that underneath your helmet.
And if you're in a leadership position and sometimes you have one group of
people talking into one ear and the other one might be the air frequency.
So you can hear the aircraft talking.
So you've got all this stuff going on inside your head and that's tricky and
kind of a pain.
But what was really painful was the way they made these headsets,
they didn't fit right.
So they were very painful and they actually squeezed your head.
So when you put your,
you put your headset on and then you put your helmet on over it and it actually
squeezed your head and it was very,
very uncomfortable.
Give you a headache.
It was just,
it just wasn't fun at all.
It sucked.
So we were out on this training mission and this is when I was a task unit
commander and it was a long one.
It was,
you know,
14 hours.
We were out there on this target and we were securing it and we were holding it
and we are searching and doing all this stuff.
It took a long time.
In about eight hours into it,
one of the junior officers came up to me and he says,
have you kept your helmet on this whole time?
And I said,
yes.
He said,
doesn't it hurt a lot?
And I said yes.
And that was it.
You know,
there was just pain to be experienced that I just sucked it up and eventually we
figured out how to,
how to cure it.
But the point is,
is that,
does it take some pain to focus?
Yes,
it is not easy.
There's,
it takes will and it takes mental effort to make it happen.
You know,
when it's there we get into kind of the things,
I think I talked about this last week,
but you know,
shut off the music,
set a goal for what you're trying to get done and then put a time limit on it.
You know that I used to race myself when I was writing those words,
you know,
like race and see how fast I could get them done and then go and that's,
that's that,
that's your focus.
Your focus is something that you control and you can make happen.
So get focused,
practice focusing,
practice focusing.
Yeah cause he kind of
at first glance or the first thought isn't that you practice focusing,
you focus on practicing or you focus on writing where you focus on,
you know,
and if he can't focus like Dang,
that sucks.
But if you practice focusing then you can focus on your writing and focus.
And also everybody knows the deadlines make you more focused when something's
due.
I mean so put a deadline on yourself and make it real somehow.
Right?
Like kind of like if someone texts you,
say,
Hey,
I'll be over in 10 minutes.
You can clean your house pretty quick in that 10 minutes.
That's true.
I mean,
but give yourself three hours to clean.
It's going to take three hours.
It'll probably take three.
And I say when,
when people would to plan for an operation,
how long does it take to plan for an operation?
We always say a half an hour longer than you have.
That's how long it takes to just get on it and start planning it and,
and go forward.
And also diet.
What do you eat
and any thoughts on using suits,
superfood,
amaranth to increase fuel,
nutrition,
amaranth.
Do you know what Amaranth is?
No,
I didn't know what it was either.
I didn't look it up and looked at it.
I looked it up.
I'm no stranger to looking things up.
No one is injured.
It's some kind of a grain,
some kind of a grain.
So what do I eat?
Uh,
in short,
I guess you'd classify me as a Paleo type of person.
I a steak,
I eat chicken,
I eat pork.
I actually,
for whatever reason,
don't like the taste of fish and seafood that much,
or eggs,
which is really unfortunate.
Yeah,
I know.
It's really bizarre.
Uh,
I eat a lot of hamburgers growing up and I kind of didn't eat a lot of seafood
grownups,
so I just am not,
not a big fan.
So I,
but I eat a lot of steak,
chicken,
pork,
I some kind of salad,
you know,
just about every day.
A Caesar,
I love Caesar Salad.
So I had a lot of that,
a spinach salad.
I put a lot of olive oil on it,
kind of Bay that this is
Peter Attia who's a really smart doctor and the,
I guess the president and CEO of something called a new set new sea,
which is this nutrition science,
which is large,
the biggest organization to study nutrition.
And he gave me a good fault or the way he explained the salads.
You know,
he looked at salads as a vehicle to eat fat by just putting a ton of olive oil
basically.
So I,
I've gotten into that lately and just really making these big salads with
massive amounts of olive oil so I can get plenty of fat.
So I'm definitely a fan of eating as much fat as possible.
You know,
if you want to,
if you want to talk about why I do that,
if you,
you know,
there's a book called good calories,
bad calories by Gary Tobbs,
which is a fantastic book and it gives a lot of background on it.
The eye,
like I said,
Peter Attia,
who's just a brilliant guy who I've had a lot of great long conversations with
because we've done some stuff together and he's actually the person that
introduced me to Tim Ferriss.
I,
I mentioned that on the first podcast,
but it's funny,
we'll go out for dinner and he wants to know about seal stuff,
but I just want to about nutrition stuff in his take on nutrition stuff so that
we have good conversations and good trade offs,
but he will,
you know,
he explains a lot of this stuff really well.
And then,
and then another good thing,
there's on the Tim Ferriss podcast,
he did an interview with Dom D'agostino who's got a really good perspective and
other another doctor that's,
you know,
a workout guy and understand nutrition very well.
So that's where I have gotten to in my life and I've got a long story,
you know,
about nutrition and maybe someday we can go into it.
It's just just the discovery and it's just with everyone else.
I mean just the fact that I guess 20 something 25 years ago,
everyone thought,
well not everyone,
but most people thought fat was bad and carbs were good.
That's not true.
Actually.
Carbs are bad and fat is good.
So it's been a,
it's been a real,
and I was lucky to have been around people that knew that early and,
and taught the information to me.
So that's,
that's the in a nutshell.
And if you want to get with the experts,
then people like Gary Tobbs,
people like Peter Attia,
people like Dom D'agostino,
they're the ones that can give you the science behind what I'm talking about or,
or what I've experienced as well.
Nutrition.
Nutrition is also one of those subjects that,
you know,
people vehemently disagree with each other on.
There was a while where I was banned by my wife from talking about nutrition
with her friends in the early days of me being completely pro fat and pro
protein and really anti carbohydrates when no one really thought that,
you know,
10 years ago in,
I would be giving all of her friends a hard time about what they reading and
what they were feeding their kids.
And my wife eventually banned me because I was problematic in that situation
cause I could see that.
Yeah.
I mean even just saying,
you know,
carbs are bad.
I mean there's a lot to that,
you know,
but to say carbs are bad,
that's a controversial thing to exactly.
Yeah.
And this another thing that I keep saying this,
but I'm not,
I'm not here to convince anybody and if you want to tell me that carbs are
great,
good for you.
I hope you enjoy type two diabetes,
get after it,
but,
but it's not like carbs.
Cute.
Thisi what you're doing right now,
you're going to start a little argument and no,
no,
I'm not going to.
Okay.
But because the bottom line is I don't,
this is stuff that I
have figured out,
I've learned from people,
I've used it myself,
and I know what works for me.
And,
and if you don't want to believe that I'm okay with that.
I'm not here to save your life.
I'm not here to change your mind.
You know?
And it's the same thing.
You know,
you've heard me say this about Jujitsu where I used to be really,
you know,
know Jiu Jitsu is better than this and she just better than that.
Now I'm like,
no,
actually there's other,
and first of all there's other perspectives,
but also that are correct and Jujitsu.
And I actually believe that you did too.
I actually do believe need to be well rounded and all this other stuff.
But
the bottom line is I'm not a,
I'm not a here to convert people,
but somebody asked what I ate and I told them.
Right.
And that's,
that's what I typically,
that is 100% true.
That's what I did.
And if you want to argue those points,
don't argue with me.
Argue with Peter Attia.
Argue with Gary Taubes,
argue with Dom D'agostino cause those guys are s w I mean Peter and dom are
scientists and doctors so they know and they will give you the facts,
which I could give you,
but I won't be doing nearly as convincingly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Next question.
A couple of guys I'd like to hear your thoughts on
Richard Mark Chenko,
Marcinko Marcinko and Henry Rollins
Marcinko and Rollins.
So let's start off with
Dick Marcinko demo.
Dick Marcinko,
who if you don't know who that is,
he was a seal in Vietnam,
a seal officer in Vietnam.
He was the founder of seal team six he created seal team six he ended up getting
in trouble with the navy and they kind of did a witch hunt on him.
And he was eventually,
I don't actually,
he did.
He did a little bit of jail time.
They found that he had falsified some travel records and maybe some money.
They found stuff on him,
but it was kind of trivial stuff that was trumped up.
Um,
but be in a forced him out of the military and he wrote a book in the 90
[inaudible] in the early nineties,
cause it,
it showed up in the seal teams right around when I got actually through buds and
under the seal team.
So it was sometime around 1990 or 1991 he wrote a book called Rogue Warrior and
it did amazing,
well sold a lot of copies and it was,
it definitely broke the mold of this idea of the quiet professional,
which was how I was small.
Certainly raised in the seal teams.
And it's something that I've,
I've obviously contradicted now because wrote a book with life,
have this podcast.
I've been on TV,
so I've,
I've definitely broke the paradigm of the quiet professional.
I absolutely try to respect the spirit of the quiet professional.
And I,
I'm not,
you know,
even if you,
the book that Lafe and I wrote isn't a book about our triumphs and everything.
We did greater,
it's a book about what we learned at usually from bad situations and humbling
experience.
That's what the book is about.
And it's an effort to pass on leadership lessons learned that we learned in a
humbling way.
So,
so there's that.
But Richard Marcinko from my perspective and the seal teams,
and again,
this was right when I came in,
he was kind of the guy that broke this mold and,
and of course there's been,
you know,
dozens and dozens of quote unquote seal books now,
but here are the first one,
very well received and definitely got some flack from the seal community.
And that is what it is now.
Now,
I worked for guys that worked for him that literally,
or you know,
they,
that he was their commanding officer.
And I remember one of them,
I said to this one senior guy that was,
had been ton of experience and I said,
you know,
you worked for Marcinko.
Well how was he?
And he looked at me with no hesitation,
said best commanding officer I ever had.
And that's,
I heard that everybody ever asked just about told me that the only people that
you'd hear anything different from would be senior senior officers,
that he was,
you know,
he'd be over the top.
He wasn't,
he didn't quite play the game and,
but there's no doubt about it.
He was a tough guy.
He was a hardcore guy and the guys that worked for him,
respected him and liked him.
The thing that I learned from him was seeing how that transition took place and
how he,
he,
the thing that got him
to where he was to,
to get that responsibility of creating seal team six,
which is this elite counter terrorist part of the navy.
You know,
obviously he was trusted and he was liked and he was respected.
And so I saw that he had gotten himself to that level,
which is very cool.
But I also saw,
and I,
yeah,
again,
this is a topic that comes up a lot.
Our strengths are often our biggest wheat weaknesses.
And so this kind of cowboy mentality,
this aggressive mentality that he had,
it got him there.
But once he got there,
he doesn't seem like he was able to reign that back in.
And that is something that I became cognizant of because no doubt,
when I was a younger guy,
when I was a young seal and then a young seal officer,
I was definitely fairly cowboyish.
And as I moved up the ranks,
I recognized that I had to mature and I had to grow up and I had to do things
differently.
I couldn't do the same things they did when I was a young platoon guy as I
could.
I had to tighten it up when I became a young officer and then there became a
platoon commander and then I became a task in your commander and I had to grow
up,
you know,
for lack of a better word.
And,
and looking back,
I should've grown up even more,
you know,
but you don't see that at the time.
So that's something that I learned from Marcenko even though I never worked for
him.
And I met him a handful of times,
you know,
but never spent any actual time with them.
But I have also seen this exact same thing with business leaders,
with CEOs is specially with CEOs that come into a company that is not doing well
and there's only one kind of person that can turn that company around.
Somebody with a dynamic personalities and with a vision,
someone that's going to kick down doors,
some of these going to make things happen.
And you see those guys go in there and they get that done and they turn those
companies around and then the real test comes is can they transition from being
that cowboy to be in that company person to be in that straight shooter
straightened Arrow that takes,
that takes the company then from survival to thrive.
And some of them make it and some of them don't.
And I look at Dick Marcinko as a cautionary tale to everybody that comes up
through the ranks and gets to that point where you're need to take it to the
next level and how you have to change what got you there
is not going to be what keeps you there.
You have to change and you have to adapt and grow.
And so I think that's important to recognize and it's important to constantly be
looking around for examples and saying,
okay,
I see.
I saw what happened there and try and push yourself forward.
So that's,
that's my,
I don't want to say my opinion because it's not really my opinion.
That's,
those are my thoughts on demo.
Dick Marcinko,
the rogue warrior.
The other one
is Henry Rollins,
and if you don't know who Henry Rollins is,
he was a young kid from the DC area who grew up in the punk rock scene in DC.
Went to a military academy,
and eventually,
even though he was kind of just a kid at at some point,
a band called black flag,
who was a incredible band led by a guitarist named Greg [inaudible].
They asked Rollins,
who was just a fan who had jumped on the stage at some point in saying one of
their songs,
they said,
hey,
they there,
they had a falling out,
or I forget what happened with their first a singer,
but the first thing that wasn't singing anymore,
if they need a new singer,
they asked Rollins to try out.
Rollins jumped on the opportunity and took that Gig and ended up being the lead
singer of the band black flag who is a really pivotal band in American rock and
roll.
And I think he took,
you know,
black flag to a whole new level.
And I've talked about,
talked about this on Tim Ferriss and I,
I'll talk about it again,
but there was an album called black flag,
my war,
which is an incredible album and it's especially an incredible album.
And if for those of you that listened to that,
for those of you younguns out there,
the records used to come on a piece of vinyl and there was two sides to it.
And so the,
this black flag album called my war had two sides to it.
And the first side sounded fairly similar to what most of black flag sounded
like prior to that,
which is just sort of punk rock,
fast beat,
whatever side too.
Was this slowed down,
heavy
dredging,
powerful music and the whole side is like that.
And that that side of that album was on my record player when I was,
I don't know,
13 or 14 years old for like a year.
I just,
all I listened to and I really related to it because it just was something that
this heavy,
this introspective,
this,
this aggression and anger was something that I wouldn't,
when I heard it for the first time,
I was like,
oh that's,
that's what I think that's,
that's what my mind is filled with
and this was sort of my,
the next thing that came after black sabbath for me because black Sabbath is the
first thing he said.
Okay,
that's what I,
that's a heavy and that's dark and I understand.
I relate to that.
The happy music that I was hearing,
I didn't understand that.
I didn't relate to it,
that heavy stuff.
When I heard that this dark stuff,
I related to it and I understood it in a,
fueled me and so Rawlins,
black flag,
my war side too,
definitely had a big impact on me.
And then from there,
eventually he was out of black flag and he formed his own band and they made an
epic record,
which is called lifetime.
Just,
uh,
again,
this,
this hit me at an age where,
uh,
what was I 16 and here comes this album called lifetime.
That was very powerful,
very raw,
very hard.
And it just,
it,
I can't imagine a better sound coming into my ears when I was 15 or 16 years old
then this album lifetime.
So myself and my buddies at the time,
we were listening to Rollins,
and again,
this was,
these were songs about power.
These were songs about,
as a matter of fact,
the cover of the lifetime album was two hands gripping the earth.
It was,
you know,
this kind of,
this message of,
at least that's how I interpreted it as that the other member,
I was a kid and I'm hearing this stuff and I'm overlaying what my thoughts of
the world are on top of it.
It sounded aggressive to me.
It sounded tough to me and that's what my mind was like at the time.
And so I put what I wanted it to,
I made it what I wanted it to be.
And to me,
two hands holding the earth,
a powerful symbol of I'm going to go,
I'm going to take over the world,
I'm going to control the world,
I'm going to make things happen.
So we actually,
when I was a kid,
we actually followed Rollins around and we would,
you know,
he played,
this was in,
I want to say this,
who's like 88 or 89 but myself and my buddies who were,
we were all under Rollins and we went and buy pie song play 10 or 15 times on
the eastern seaboard.
Maybe it wasn't til maybe,
maybe it was 10 times.
And we know this is back in the day,
this is,
you know,
he's playing in clubs that are the size of your living room,
you're in.
We'd help them on load their instruments and we'd help them offload and we'd
hang out with them afterwards.
And it was,
it was great,
it was cool.
And that was my experience.
And I was definitely,
I think that had a big impact on me.
Another thing I hadn't mentioned this about light,
that album lifetime in between the songs,
you know,
if you look at vinyl records and there's a space in between the songs
and there's,
you know,
there's like a standard,
I don't know what,
you know,
there's a standard of two millimeters,
let's say.
And when I first got that lifetime record,
this space in between the songs you could see it was,
it was tiny.
And that's because the,
the,
the one song would end in boom,
that the other song,
after a moment of silence,
boom,
the next song would kick in.
And that's what the album was like,
this intense just driving,
getting after it.
So we would go to those shows and we would just go completely nuts in,
get our insane mosh pit destruction on.
So out of that,
you know,
spawned this.
And the other thing was cool,
you know,
Rollins was,
we were not into drinking,
we were not our drugs and neither was Rawlins.
So he was this kind of,
you know,
we'd see Rollins doing pushups before the show is we'd say,
Oh yeah,
this,
this guys like us.
You know,
this,
I relate to this guy cause I want to be strong and I don't want to do drugs and
I'm staying clean and he's staying clean.
And so we had this good thing going.
But again,
this is my 15 year old brain.
And uh,
so what happens?
So I took all that to mean that's the way life is.
For instance,
Rollins has a big tattoo on his back that says search and destroy.
Okay,
I took that literally,
you know,
okay,
this,
I need to search and destroy.
How do you do that?
Okay,
what is the most hardcore thing?
What does the most physical thing?
What is,
how do you get control?
How do you do?
How do you be aggressive in the nth degree?
You know how you do it?
You'd be a commando.
And so,
so those,
again,
those weird twisted interpretations of my mind said to me,
okay,
that means you need to be a commando.
Hmm.
And that's what I did.
That's how I am.
That's one of the,
one of the,
I would say one of those factors that led me on the path that I'm,
that I'm here today.
So went through seal training and actually interestingly the first Lollapalooza
tour,
and we'd have to Google this and see when this was,
but it was the first Lollapalooza and Rollins was playing and they played down
in somewhere in San Diego.
Lollapalooza came and I went
and I didn't want to pay for it for whatever reason.
So I went backstage and I waited until I saw the Rollins and I saw Rollins and I
said a Rawlins,
he said,
hey,
and you could see,
he kind of recognized me.
I mean we,
he recognized me and went over and said Hi.
And I said,
Hey,
can you get me into the show?
And I've got a couple of buddies with me and he said,
it'd be easier to get you into Fort Knox.
It was kind of weird because back in the day we would sit there and hang out
with them and help him load his van and get walked right in.
And it was just really cool to have that much interaction with somebody that you
are into.
I mean,
you can't do that normally.
And all of a sudden there it was.
Now he's in Lollapalooza and even though he's on tour and he doesn't know
anybody there,
there's a guy there,
me and I can't get in.
So it was,
you know,
it was cool.
Um,
but it was definitely a sign to me that,
that things were a little different now.
Mm.
And he had kind of made it right.
I guess he made it now and he ended up having some pretty big,
or he had some bigger records that did better than,
than lifetime.
But the way it kind of continues,
the way this story continues is that wrong ones was a guy when I was a kid that
talked about Vietnam vets,
and if you read any of his,
you know,
we used to write books and I'd read his books and he would talk about Vietnam
vets.
Now this guy taught him so much about discipline and then he talked to me and he
had this tattoo,
this search and destroy.
And in his books are in his shows.
He would talk about the violence and the fights and all these things.
And,
and he even talked about like,
missions
remain calm,
prepare to destroy.
That's from a song that's from a Henry Rollins song,
remain calm,
prepare to destroy.
So he,
he kind of
had this thing that I thought was cool
when I was 14
and then I actually went in and I did this stuff,
you know,
I actually went and did the stuff that he had talked about and that he spent his
career talking about.
And so all of a sudden this connection,
this sort of,
um,
yeah,
this connection that I had with him,
all of a sudden it kind of faded because I,
I looked at it from a different light as it was no longer me looking at someone
thinking this guy's done this cool stuff.
It was actually starting to look at him thinking he didn't do this cool stuff.
Okay.
And,
and now I think when I see them now,
and it's weird,
I think he's about 10 years older than me,
maybe 12 years older than me.
So he,
I can kind of see
it's a little bit of a glimpse into the future,
but you know,
because you see a guy that's a certain years older than you and you know what he
looked like when he was 25 and you know what he looked like when he was 35 and
45 and now he's probably 55 and I can see what he looks like and what he did
look like.
So I kind of,
I see him now and he seems to be a result of that life that he ended up with,
which is Hollywood and kind of famous and kind of being in movies and being a
rock star
and
it's,
I don't have the same,
like I said,
connection that I,
that I did.
But like I said,
when I was a kid,
when I was 13 years old,
when I was 14 years old,
when I was 15 years old,
I was,
I was definitely,
I definitely
took some things from him and apply them to my life and I'd love,
I'd love to meet up with him.
I know he lives up in La and if at some point,
Hank,
if you're listening,
let me know.
Let's,
let's link up.
We'll talk about the old times,
but you know,
I think that might might even be something to close with is when,
when you're dealing with people,
people
are not who you want them to be.
Your idols,
the people that you look up to,
the people that you think are cool are not,
they're not that person.
You kill your idols.
It now there's things that we can learn from people,
but they aren't going to be what you think they are or they aren't going to be
even what they should be.
Those people,
when you take them and you put them on a pedestal,
they're not deserving of that pedestal.
They're going to be fault that they're going to be weak.
They're going to be ego maniacal.
They can be condescending.
They're going to be all those negative things to me,
lazy,
they're going to be entitled,
they're going to be short sighted.
They're not going to be perfect
far from it and that's fine.
That's okay.
You learn from their weaknesses and you learn from their strengths of course,
and you mimic them and you,
you emulate them.
But equally is important.
You learn from their faults and you see what not to do
because the bottom line is you can't control other people.
I know we spent time tonight talking about manipulation and influence,
but the bottom line is you can't control them.
You can't make people be what you want them to be.
Okay?
The only person that you can control
is you
view.
And that's what you've got to focus on.
Focus on you.
Focus on focus.
Focus on making yourself who you want to be.
Faster,
smarter,
stronger,
more humble,
less ego.
Discipline your body
so you can free your mind.
Get up early and go get after it
and be that person that you want to be.
And that's not easy and not everyone can do it.
And I'm not here to tell everybody that everybody can do it,
but it can happen.
And it does happen
through one small decision at a time
and every one of those decisions important in building
you.
And that's all I've got for today.
So at every bum,
everyone out there.
Thanks for listening.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for subscribing.
That's kind of how we know that people are listening.
Thanks for reviewing.
When you get the chance,
let us know what you think and let the world know what you think.
Spread the word.
We want to keep doing these podcasts,
so thanks and most of all to everyone out there.
Thank you for getting after it.
This is Jocko.
Until next time
out.